star wars battlefront pushed out its
last DLC for the season rogue one
Scariff it marks the second time dice
and EA have been able to release and
market a battlefront product alongside a
Disney star wars movie decisions to cut
game development happen all the time yet
when battlefront season DLC sets a bar
it sets expectations oddly enough
surprises too with the free x-wing VR
mission that was tacked about fronts
latest update still the robe one scared
package drops and for me it was kind of
disappointing like in its previous dlc
updates battlefront brings new maps new
game modes vehicle weapons to new heroes
it's a substantial list of additions yet
realistically what is your average
players experience with these features
vampire the new infiltration mode is
panic inducing and pretty fun similar to
death stars DLC battle station here the
rebels push through Imperials in three
phases starting in a frantic space
battle and finishing up on the shores of
Scariff the maps are small but polished
and true to the Star Wars rogue one
spectacle yet the mode is missing
something big Imperial walkers
thankfully Scariff DLC contains Walker
assault but for some odd reason the mode
is stripped down fewer uplink stations
no controllable land or air vehicles
you'd at least figured you could operate
the Walker turrets but no that's kind of
a bummer especially considering the
Bespin DLC pulled off the standard
Walker assault and there weren't even a
datz on Bespin and Empire Strikes Back
you got two new weapons in the Scariff
DLC which are only unlockable through
Hut contracts where you must purchase a
contract with credits and then complete
a few challenges in order to get that
weapon for chronixx DT 29 one of the
challenges requires you to get 25 kills
as the man himself so now you're forced
to scour the map out of action for that
random villain powerup which other
players are also stalking and waiting
for or you can play the heroes vs.
villains mode which heightens the chance
to play as krenek the downside is now
you're grinding a mode on maps that
aren't featured in this new DLC
you're also able to pilot the new Ewing
from the movie only if you're randomly
selected when playing as a rebel and in
the first phase of infiltration why not
add this ship in fighter squadron and
the movies tie strikers here but just as
another random power up with no player
interaction engage it and one just zips
around occasionally killing rebels when
Bespin steal see said you could fly the
cloud car you could if you found it
overall rogue one scarce content felt
missing compared to battle fronts last
add-ons playing scare felt like dal back
potential on the other hand the latest
update brings the free playstation vr
x-wing mission and it felt like the
polar opposite to the Scariff dlc for
just a 15-minute mission it was so much
better being at the helm of an x-wing
manually flipping on s-foils tearing
through TIE fighters looping around the
Rebel Alliance fleet it was all
mind-blowing in an interview with the
missions developer criterion games two
of the game's designers said that the
intricate x-wing cockpit they designed
is now part of the official Lucasfilm
Star Wars Canon on mentioning how the VR
flight controls felt more fluid and less
stiff compared to Bal fronts they told
me it's because they rebuilt them from
the ground up criterion games even
recorded new lines for after alan tudyk
the voice behind Rowan's k2s oh just for
this production it was apparent that
their intent wasn't to create a battle
front side mission but to present a
sliver of what could undoubtedly be a
fully functioning Star Wars x-wing VR
game Bravo one head on over for a
mediator
bravoteens this is red leader take
evasive action we'll cover you negative
red fight will under attack the rogue
one x-wing V our mission and rogue one
Scariff showed me two paths of where
star wars game could go with EA games
dishing out many Star Wars titles to
various developers over the next few
years it worries me that this might
become an unfortunate trend even if a
Star Wars experience is shorter and more
focused I'd rather have that than a map
pack that feels rushed in order to meet
a deadline two one mark
[Music]
you